[Music]
and you lie we sued news is in China not
in China well she sounds like a fool
what you say it all Chinese for I said
Oh Chinese yeah so made it by the fat
Buddhist so maybe it isn't Chinese booty
Oh a Chinese restaurant
it's suing a customer who falsely claim
they had maggots what yeah the dish was
called maggots their fire what because
if that's the case it is fine you don't
thank you man you like the human a human
like no but at a glance it looks like it
says human being like oh and then I read
it again I'm like oh my friend Michael
ha had a Chinese buffet and their things
a human beef until they closed down they
never changed it just a human being like
hu ma n yeah it was just a typo but they
never changed it yeah it was delicious
you lost your opportunity miss Bart said
he wants to eat human in another episode
I want to eat real human I don't want to
type oh I don't eat cow that's call him
and funny a title and I don't want to
eat a real human but I understand I
would if I needed to
oh if I need to tell you what to you
would you're an experienced you did yeah
right now you keep contradicting
yourself contracepting myself yeah
contraceptive so this happened in
Indiana this customer claimed to have
found maggots in a napkin dispenser
what's the problem is that in the food I
know it's on your napkin you like wipe
it on your face get rid of the napkins
you don't eat the napkin if you want to
you just wants to argue why don't
relationship I don't want you can use
the tablecloth yeah you could also take
the napkin and put up a white fly saying
you give up there's a lot of different
uses a lot of things I give up this
restaurants done so the restaurants
called the Great Wall of Fame of course
buffet like I said what an original
meaning so what happened here was that
this woman said that she opened up or
like she saw in the napkin dispenser cuz
it's one of those clear napkin
dispensers
it's not transparent but like you can
kind of see through it so she found like
little white things near the bottom of
it right so she claimed that that was
maggots and she was like oh my god I'm
just sick to my stomach and she ended up
leaving that restaurant she posted this
[ __ ] on Facebook there's pictures no I
don't have pictures um but she said that
she was she was just like oh my god I
can't believe that they had maggots in
her napkin dispenser right so then
that's when they went to go investigate
this place who's they what do you call
um the food inspector people where did
he call FDA Health Department oh yeah
Health Department they went to go
investigate because of the in response
to the complaint and then they open the
napkin dispenser and they concluded that
it was just little pieces of a napkin I
could have told you that lady so then
now this lady sent a letter to the
restaurant apologizing for her mistake
saying that she was mortified and
distraught and then that she deleted her
entire facebook profile in response to
that because she realized how she ever
tell that [ __ ] restaurant though like
yo there's maggots in here or she just
was like go tell everybody
[ __ ] them now the restaurant they have
an intention to file a lawsuit against
her [ __ ] yeah yeah and a considerable
drop in sales since her post they also
lost a catering order worth at least
$200 so this is affected their business
yeah they're like even though she's
apologizing he was still you know money
because like even if you apologize it
doesn't change the fact that you [ __ ]
their business yeah and this is what I'm
talking about people aren't held
responsible for the [ __ ] that they say
you think you could just push it up and
just [ __ ] somebody over walk away yeah
what she did was she apologized to the
restaurant but she says she took
everything down but she didn't update
any other people so now all those people
are still left going I'm not gonna ever
eat there they got maggots
and like rumors go around and people
don't ever come back and that's the
problem like people don't see the power
of the words yeah and even just being
like a Good Samaritan like if he saw
maggots in the napkins instead of just
freaking out and running away about it
at least you could tell the restaurant
can clear it up so no one else has to
see it but she's so selfish and only
focused on her own emotions that she
just [ __ ] bounced if they were real
magus she wanted the attention like oh
my god look at what happened to me you
guys like I'm a good person look I'm
helping everyone else people are
literally looking for [ __ ] just so they
could feel special yes it's so sad like
what the [ __ ] were you thinking dude
that's so terrible so what happens with
like Yelp reviews as long as they're
true it's fine you can really see up and
then dispute it right which it works
like 50% of the tuggers some people just
say [ __ ] just to say [ __ ] and there is a
reviewing process will they'll be like
okay well this is [ __ ] and they'll
take it down which does happen a lot to
be honest with you some people just
write [ __ ] so for example with one of
the ice cream stores that I have
somebody just broke this review they're
like I hate this ice cream but didn't
even try it once are like just one here
and I was gonna go but I don't think I
liked it I don't think I was gonna like
it and it gave us a one-star thank you
they didn't go into the estate they
didn't try the ice cream this gave us a
one-star so that that happens like here
and there this happened like five or six
times remember are you talking about one
where they give you a one-star for the
parking situation when that's not even
in your control so we had to dispute
that too it's like we don't control
parking you know their like their
parking is terrible they get a one start
they should care more about their
customers just like we don't own a lot
like what are you talking about so
sometimes - like they'll do they'll take
it down but sometimes they won't because
they have to base it on what the
business does so we can't control that
you know so what do you want us to do
about this yeah
and even though I feel like when you can
change things it's like when people
don't bring it up at that time because
sometimes yeah it might it might be too
salty for your palate and then a lot of
people go on Yelp oh it was too salty
when you could have totally been like
hey this is a little too salty for my
taste could you bring it back in yeah so
we always make it I'm always afraid of
taking food back though cuz I'm like I'm
scared of people [ __ ] I don't like it
as long as you're nice like most of the
staff always would rather fix it for you
so you come back cuz you don't come back
as you lost a customer he lost word of
mouth and they want a tip - yeah
ultimately like I think ultimately if
you're a server your goal is to not spit
in people's food your goal is to make
more money that day so if there's a
chance for them to impress someone a
people jump on that chance sometimes
like in the past when I would return
things came back with the loogie
not like they would give me this look
like how dare you ask for this to be
returned like or give me attitude or
something wrong like god damn I'm trying
to be nice as possible just tell you
like hey can you like or they gave me
something because I hate onions right
I'll be like oh yeah I asked for this
with no onions and then they'll be like
what there are people like that are
waiters who day they take that there are
no life into their work - yeah they ruin
everybody else
I don't know now this story has been
spreading so maybe their business might
come back up because now people know
that it was just a stupid ass lady I
don't know I don't think I would go back
so like I think if let's say you guys
posted a story you're like I saw maggots
at the at the coffee shop right here I'd
be like oh damn and even if you came
back and you were like hey you guys my
bad it wasn't maggot there was just
pieces of napkin I would be like yeah
like if there were maggots on the
restaurant already sounds like negative
you know but I mean does this lady have
a lot of money or they're like [ __ ]
we're coming for whatever you got I
don't know I already start off not
believing people if I like the place so
if I like some place and I read
something oh don't go there they got 9
minutes feels a little [ __ ] [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] those maggots if I
like the place already all right I got
the places back all the time I mean I
think we're all like that in this room
because we all have heard the horror
stories of just restaurant and how clean
they are yeah we're still like [ __ ] it I
haven't makes it delicious cuz if I have
a yelp review in my mind that's the Yelp
review and I don't give a [ __ ] what they
say so if I eat someplace on my own
specific like a four and a half star
place it's forever four and a half star
in my mind and then people start writing
whatever it is starts dropping out doing
an app I just go everyone else's [ __ ]
trip and it's good until I try it and it
is bad then I'm like [ __ ] it is to half
now that's pretty but it's so crazy how
like you're right like so many people
can say like such negative things to
suck on two places and I'm like oh it's
only those three stars like I actually
really like it a lot you know but then
how many of us actually go out of our
ways to write like y'all pretty a
positive one
right like it's really good I always
write a good one really like if it's
really bad I read out of this world
amazing for me like I think I've read in
to review so that we're good and one
though I was like pigs people just want
to hear themselves or just see you just
want to talk you know I mean that's be
heard you know what like I said like
Yelp is a great thing and it's also a
bad thing at the same time it's great
because a lot of these restaurants who
didn't get limelight before can shine
like if they are really good you know
even taco trucks can get hella reviews
now like public perception is a huge day
know like some some places are arguably
grateful though for people that review
like I look at reviews on Amazon I look
at reviews like whenever I'm shopping at
any like online shop like I'm so great
I'm like thank you because it was
definitely a double-edged sword is just
like the hard part is like within this
community I wish y'all would add this
apart where other people can respond to
these other people as well oh yeah no no
other people yeah so if it's a Yelp
community like they said that it should
be an open forum because they what they
say is definitive and there's nobody can
say anything about it right you don't
mind you like for example people who
write these reviews and they go well
today I had a really bad day [ __ ] cares
about your day you dumb they can reply
shut the [ __ ] yeah that somebody could
be right well what the [ __ ] your [ __ ]
review I suck my dick exactly it could
be like the like it would be just like
another youtube comment section yeah you
know people wouldn't defend you and be
like wait no this is what it is and this
is not what it is yeah there was a
magazine hores [ __ ] napkin crumbs
like you can write a review like oh you
saw that this was a negative one but if
you actually like the place write a
positive reviews about ways people think
twice about the verbage and usage and
also you would have to have proof like
you can't just write [ __ ] just to write
[ __ ] like some people they go I'm a
connoisseur of this what does that mean
[ __ ] [ __ ] I drink water every day I'm
not a water connoisseur how the [ __ ]
does that mean you know I mean like it's
just it's just a little weird space I
don't know I like you though
I do but I don't do under my name I do
it under a different name and I only get
four to five stars what's your name I'm
just kidding okay it's like I either
give four to five stars or I don't say
anything at all if it's unless it's
super super bad but then if it was bad
then I've definitely talked to the
restaurant already first it's like yo
man like
she's unacceptable peppa [ __ ] like that
and if they till still tell me to [ __ ]
off then well write something but it's
been I don't think I've written a
one-star review in late years that's
true
well maybe we've leveled up too and we
don't we don't frequent those places
anymore
yeah and that's also - even before I own
my own personal businesses I just never
did it because my parents owned a
personal business right and so like I
just I know like how powerful this stuff
is because if some people [ __ ] with you
so people don't so why is it your
position to go ahead trying to tear this
business down just because you didn't
like how the food tastes but other
people did so why does your opinions so
important for you to destroy this
person's livelihood yeah you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]